bonsoir à tous dans l'actualité ce soir
la grève fait trébucher la sncf à la
veille des départs en vacances la vente
des billets tgv totalement suspendu
entre le sud est et paris elle ne peut
plus garantir la circulation des trains
l'enquète progresse à grenoble après le
lynchage sans raison apparente d'un
étudiant l'auteur présumé des coups de
couteau s'est rendu il a 20 ans il doit
être déféré au parquet ce soir les
contrastes de l'économie alors que le
chômage est au plus haut une étude du
pôle emploi révèle que des grands
secteurs en manque de bras
aide à domicile restauration vendeurs
dans 40 % des cas ils ont du mal à
recruter
pourquoi reportage et explications la
bataille de la voiture est relancé à
paris bertrand delanoë annonce la
fermeture dans les deux ans d'une partie
des fameuses voies sur berge les
réactions dans un instant enquête sur
ces femmes qui se met au sport de combat
confrontés aux risques d'agression elles
veulent savoir se défendre de nombreux
courts ouvrent leurs portes c'est le
dossier de cette édition
et puis le grand défi de la soirée les
semi amateurs de quevilly 4e division
face au paris saint germain en demi
finale de la coupe de france
un monde les sépare reportage juste
avant le coup d'envoi
bienvenue dans ce journal est avant de
développer ses titres ses images de
chine le pays a été secoué par un
nouveau tremblement de terre cette fois
dans les montagnes pas très loin du
tibet une ville entière s'est effondré
il pourrait y avoir des milliers de
morts
gilles rabin les immeubles modernes en
béton presque tous tenus même si la
plupart sont fissurés mais les maisons
traditionnelles construites en bois en
terre et en brique se sont écroulées
d'un coup sûr leurs habitants au moment
où il se réveiller selon des témoignages
recueillis sur place
85% de la ville historique du chou
seraient détruites
c'est le tibet de sina et le tibet
historique qui a été frappé une série de
hauts plateaux entourée de montagnes à
4000 mètres d'altitude une des provinces
les plus isolés les plus pauvres les
plus difficiles d'accès en chine une
région sous-équipés aussi très peu de
pelleteuses et engins de déblaiement
la plupart du temps les sauveteurs
locaux travaillent tamanu même des
moines tibétains en robe traditionnelle
tente de retrouver des survivants
ce soir 900 personnes seulement auraient
été sortis des décombres
pékin envoient d'urgence plus de 5000
soldats et pompiers en renfort mais ils
ne seront pas sur les lieux du séisme
avant une vingtaine d'heures au moins en
chine depuis le tremblement de terre du
sichuan qui au printemps 2008 avait fait
88 morts et provoqué une vague de colère
populaire dans tout le pays
les séismes sont politiquement
ultrasensible l'actualité en france avec
je vous le disais en titre les
répercussions de l'épreuve de force à la
sncf 9e jour de grève la direction reste
ferme la cgt aussi conséquences en
pleine période de vacances l'entreprise
vient de suspendre toutes les ventes de
billets sur les tgv entre paris et le
sud est lyon marseille montpellier nice
aller et retour
fabien shadow même hangar il est
désormais impossible d'acheter un billet
pour le sud est et ce jusqu'à dimanche
après huit jours de grève à la sncf la
direction suspend son système de
réservation
l'agente avec il travaille veulent même
pas réservé de m moi j'étais sur lui
aucun billet sur aucune garde il n'y
avait pas de vent dit rien du tout bref
dans le tract sais pas où ça va on
compromet pas être pas comprendre
pourquoi tout ça c'est tout depuis
quelques jours les trains lorsqu'il y en
a sont bondées en arrêtant la vente des
billets la sncf espère limiter la gêne
des voyageurs on préfère suspendre les
ventes pour assurer aux clients qui ont
réservé leur place et voyager ainsi dans
les meilleures conditions possibles
à 48 heures du chassé-croisé des
vacanciers ce conflit tombe bien mal
autre ils trouvent leur compte faute de
contrôleurs j'ai déjà voyagé depuis une
semaine je suis allé à dans les alpes
gratuitement je suis redescendu à
marseille là je remonte à paris
gratuitement sont prévues pour demain 3
tgv sur 4 dans le sud est
un train régional sur deux est déjà la
sncf promet des remboursements c'est
trop tôt pour dire on va parler que les
associations mais vous allez on il y
aura des mesures de remboursement
oui de remboursement des clients
victimes de la grève
oui un petit signe d'espoir cependant
selon la cgt des négociations vont
commencer demain au niveau régional
voilà pour cette annonce bonsoir
isabelle ce test vous êtes en direct à
marseille là bas la situation est en
train de tourner au casse-tête
oui en fait c'est surtout là c'est la
confusion et kyriat un initié à la gare
saint charles
alors il n'y a pas foule parce qu'on est
en pleine de périodes de vacances ici
dans le sud mais toute la journée on
voit des usagers qui cherchent des
informations sur les trains en partance
et des informations qui changent tout le
temps alors il ya 14 tgv sur dix sept
qui circulent pour paris mais vous
l'avez vu ils sont complets et même
bondé avec les passagers d'être annulée
puis le point noir c'est la circulation
des ter deux trains sur 8 en direction
de nice
aucune circulation sur la vallée du
rhône et puis des difficultés à priori
d'antibes d'anticipation pardon puisque
ce matin une dame nous disait que la
sncf lui avait vendu un billet pour
tarascon et que ce train était annulé
une demi heure plus tard alors beaucoup
d exaspération et qui ne devraient pas
s'apaiser demain puisque le mouvement
continue et entre dans son neuvième jour
isabelle steiss à marseille merci
isabelle et puis si vous êtes appelés à
voyager pour ces vacances scolaires vers
le sud-est ou vers paris sur ces lignes
la plus fréquentée de france vous êtes
bien sûr invités à vous renseigner
l'actualité judiciaire avec cette
avancée après l'agression d'un étudiant
à grenoble battu et poignardé en pleine
rue
l'auteur présumé des coups de couteau
s'est rendu il n'a que 20 ans sur place
benoit gadret olivier jacqueline cet
individu parmi lesquels quatre mineurs
dont un âgé de 14 ans ont donc été
présenté aujourd'hui au juge
d'instruction
parmi eux l'auteur présumé des deux
coups de couteau un jeune âgé de 20 ans
connu pour des faits de violence
recherché par la police il s'est
présenté de lui même aux enquêteurs il
reconnaît qu'il était bien de détenteurs
du couteau qu'il a été utilisé mais il
prétend que les blessures occasionnées à
la victime ont été fait involontairement
la victime aurait pu tomber sur le
couteau dans des conditions qui sont
très très mal définis pour les
enquêteurs martin un étudiant de 24 ans
a été clairement victime ici d'un
lynchage gratuit mais les avocats de la
défense
sans nier la violence de leurs clients
ont une vision différente du dossier
selon la victime et ses amis avaient
également bu dans le tramway
l'étudiant était très énervé il s'agit
davantage d'une affaire de beuvry c'est
à dire de deux groupes qui sont
passablement éméché et alcoolisée en fin
de soirée un accrochage verbal des
insultes de part et d'autre les
auditions menées par les deux juges
d'instruction saisis se poursuivent
actuellement
l'auteur présumé des coups de couteau
sera incarcéré la décision était prise
pour les autres le juge des libertés et
de la détention se prononcera dans la
soirée
on revient maintenant sur l'annoncé
destructions de maisons sur le littoral
atlantique on a évoqué ici même depuis
plusieurs jours la révolte des habitants
mais elle est en train de prendre de
nouvelles proportions hier soir en
visite près d'oléron le préfet de
charente maritime a été bousculé il n'a
pu quitter la réunion que grâce aux crs
ce reportage ann guy était alain
darrigrand le préfet quittent la réunion
précipitamment pendant une heure et
demie il a tenté de convaincre sans
succès le commerce l'activité des leurs
qui a pas des personnes neudorf cas pas
de que c'est dur ne vous pouvez
continuer de commercer
comment voulez vous que les commerces
mardi ville du ponant
la discussion tourne court les sinistrés
tentent de retenir le pression du port
val kilmer
finalement il se fraie un passage on va
perdre nos maisons nos commerces du
village c'est impossible c'est
impossible leur village ces boyardville
petit port de pêche et surtout cité
historique ancien camp de base pour la
construction de fort boyard sous
napoléon
aujourd'hui les anciens logements des
ouvriers du fort sont en sursis
a priori rang du tournoi russe a disparu
et salé la population comprend pas la
police ne trouvera pas c'est une
décision unilatérale sans présentation
dans la zone noire
cent quarante sept habitations la moitié
du village pendant la tempête l'eau est
montée jusqu'à 1 mètre 80 mais dans
cette maison seulement quelques
centimètres
le propriétaire veut saisir la justice
c'est une maison de pêcheur qui a été
construite avant 1850 que nous avons
rénové et or de inondations nous avons
eu seulement dix centimètres d'eau 10 cm
d'eau c'est une maison qui est au dessus
du niveau de la mer donc ça ne risque
absolument rien et on veut aller offrir
à boyardville
la résistance s'organise le bras de fer
avec l'état ne fait que commencer
à noter que ségolène royal présidente de
la région poitou charentes veut prendre
la tête de la protestation elle adressé
une lettre ouverte au président de la
république et au premier ministre
on écoute beaucoup de brutalité de la
part du gouvernement dans les
différentes annonces
donc je pense que maintenant le temps
est à la fois aller coûte à
l'identification des raisons qui ont
poussé le gouvernement
une façon aussi brutale et de façon si
caricaturale et puis enfin de faire
émerger des propositions et ségolène
royal qui demande avec des maires la
suspension du zonage et l'ouverture
d'une nouvelle concertation autres
titres de l'actualité
la bataille de la voiture de
l'automobile est relancé à paris
bertrand delanoë repart à l'offensive
il a annoncé aujourd'hui la fermeture
prochaine d'une partie des voies sur
berge
l'un des axes les plus fréquentés de la
capitale jean françois feer et emmanuel
maurel elle traverse paris d'est en
ouest longe la seine et quelques-uns des
monuments les plus célèbres de la
capitale
pourtant les voies sur berges sont
aujourd'hui davantage prisé des voitures
que des promeneurs malgré l'évidente
intérêt touristique sur le pont change
en plein centre de paris
le coeur historique comme on dit à
gauche saint michel à droite châtelet
derrière moi notre dame de paris est
toujours sous le pied ce flot incessant
de véhicules 40 milles par jour selon le
projet du maire de paris rive gauche la
circulation serait tout simplement
interdite sur 2 km mais limité sur la
rive droite comme c'est déjà le cas le
dimanche où l'été lors de l'opération
paris plage des lieux de détente serait
aménagé un écran de cinéma en plein air
un parc floral sous le pont de l'alma
ou encore des îlots artificiels à la
concorde là où aujourd'hui il n'y a que
du bitume c'est sûr ce serait bien et
supprimer mais oui de la voiture voilà
le problème supprimer les voies sur
berge veut aussi lier de se passer d'un
des principaux axes de circulation de la
capitale
inévitablement le trafic va se reporter
chez les bars alentours déjà fortement
embouteillée bien entendu les
automobilistes sont courants
je ne donne jamais de la cour
monsieur delanoë a décidé de se mettre
en guerre contre les automobilistes
l'adjointe au maire elle se veut
rassurante chiffres à l'appui il y
aurait sept minutes de plus de deux
trajets en voiture pour traverser paris
en 1967 ont posé le débat aves la
voiture prenait ses aises
la voici aujourd'hui banni des villes
lyon et bordeaux déjà protégé leur
fleuve l'économie avec le paradoxe du
chômage il est mise en évidence par le
pôle emploi
il recense dans une étude les secteurs
qui manque de main d'oeuvre ils sont
nombreux d'après une estimation dans
quatre cas sur dix ils ont beaucoup de
mal à recruter enquête julien beaumont
lorraine christophe lourd avec notre
bureau à toulouse le lèche-vitrine
meilleur moyen pour trouver un emploi
six affiches ont tendance à se
multiplier depuis quelques mois comme
ici au forum des halles à paris prenez
ce magasin de cosmétiques
deux nouvelles boutiques doivent ouvrir
il faut recruter 10 cdi et appel à des
cabinets extérieurs les aider à recruter
et on a du mal à trouver des personnes
et personne n'est fait à l'un des
candidats c'est pourquoi on sait pas
exactement pourquoi après on a des
candidats mais c'est pas forcément à
leur profil une tendance nationale en
moyenne quatre offres d'emploi sur dix
ne sont pas pourvus alors ici pour
dénicher la perle rare
on n'hésite pas à prendre du personnel
sans qualification j'ai passé un
entretien ça c'est au bout de deux trois
semaines après j'ai commencé ici mais
justement j'avais pas de pharmacie un
maquillage donc j'ai été d'abord formés
en interne et depuis je travaille en
tant que conseillère de vente vendeurs
une denrée rare qu'il faut à tout prix
garder ses enseignes multiplient donc
les efforts financiers dès le premier
mois ils ont droit à un pourcentage sur
le chiffre d'affaires qui réalise ce qui
fait que ça leur fait un salaire
supérieur aux autres enseignes et y
reste et du coup il reste est non
seulement il reste mais travaille avec
beaucoup de bonne volonté des terrasses
pleines
la saison démarre bien à toulouse en
salle c'est le coup de feu mais pour ce
patron recruté c'est mission impossible
surtout que les petits postes
les postes qui sont à khartoum à mi
temps là c'est très dur même des
étudiants nage pas les garder quoi ils
veulent absolument
ne pas travailler le soir dans ça c'est
embêtant même sur l'eau proposée
salaires qui sont adéquates
la vie de famille et vie familiale la
vie sociale puis j'ai l'impression que
les salaires eric ça va le dire
d'arrivée avec son diplôme de cuisinier
il a été aux antilles sur un paquebot ou
encore à deux villes avant de finir ici
il a reçu 15 offres d'emploi à eau coûte
beaucoup dans l'hôtellerie restauration
parce qu'en plus de 10 si je travaillais
au c1 en plus certains soirs dans des
raisons que charles decoene ligne et qui
trouve pas dans puise signé l'un des
mythiques qui devrait embaucher le plus
après les commerciaux les vende les
ingénieurs les secrétaires et les aides
à domicile des intentions d'embauché car
pour beaucoup la crise est passé en
quarante pour cent des cas les
intentions d'embauché sont prévus pour
créer des postes
c'est plutôt une bonne nouvelle est
qu'ils nous indiquent que l'année 2010
serait une année dynamique en termes
d'emploi
cette tension sur les recrutements
concernent aussi les secteurs plus
inattendus ici c'est une formation
une vingtaine d'élèves qui devrait
devenir en juin conseiller sportif
isabelle dauliach est une ancienne
commerciale
à 36 ans elle a décidé de se reconvertir
convaincus par les propositions de ces
pays de la part de nombreux patrons de
clubs vous aurez votre diplôme peuvent
aller le voir parce qu'effectivement on
embauche
au moins trois clubs sont proposés ça
déjà rien qu'en ile-de-france 200
personnes vont obtenir leur diplôme
cette année insuffisant car il n'y a
plus de 400 postes à pourvoir
voilà pour être plus précis pour essayer
de bien comprendre agnès molinier nous a
rejoint bonsoir agnès alors est ce que
c'est une question de salaire d'image de
marque
quelles sont les explications commençons
par les salaires david et bien ce n'est
pas l'élément le plus dissuasif j'ai
pris trois exemples d'après l'insee des
chiffres de 2008
par exemple pour un cuisinier le salaire
mensuel net sera de 1270 euros pour un
ouvrier du bâtiment par exemple le
peintre se fera 1470 euros et enfin pour
un commercial vrp 1850 on le voit fait
pas le pérou mais c'est pas non plus le
pire ce qui se passe c'est qu' un
deuxième problème c'est la réputation de
certains métiers on l'a vu pour les
métiers nous quand les salaires sont
très bas et qu'en plus il se double de
conditions difficiles d'horaires et bien
ils ont une mauvaise image
et puis contrairement à l'allemagne la
formation en alternance est peu répandue
en france ce qui fait que les métiers
manuels
il conserve encore et toujours une
mauvaise image et il ya un troisième
élément qui lui aussi est très français
david c'est le manque de mobilité
les salariés français sont les moins
mobiles surtout quand ils sont peu
qualifiés prenons un exemple
si par exemple un chef d'entreprise
cherche un plombier ici à marseille est
bien à ce moment-là peut-être le chômeur
qui va chercher un emploi tombe bien et
bien il va être en bretagne et comme
pôle emploi ne centralise pas les offres
et les demandes et bien le breton ne
sera peut-être jamais mis en contact
avec le marseillais et l'offre d'emploi
eh bien elle ne sera jamais pour lui
merci agnès précise que les chiffres que
vous donniez sont des salaires médians
pour chaque profession
le débat sur les retraites suite le
conseil d'orientation des retraites le
cor a remis officiellement son rapport à
françois fillon
on évoquait hier ses prévisions
alarmantes elles sont d'ailleurs
contesté aujourd'hui par plusieurs
syndicats image signée sébastien
laffargue est à noter que martine aubry
a esquissé dans une tribune publiée par
le journal le monde ce que sera la
position du parti socialiste elle exclu
tout recul de l'âge légal de départ en
retraite et donne la priorité à de
nouvelles recettes en évoquant l'
élargissement de l'assiette des
cotisations à la valeur ajoutée
encore un prélèvement sur les stock
options voici ce soir l'exemple
britannique signe particulier là bas les
plus de 60 ans sont si nombreux à
vouloir continuer à travailler qu'il
existe maintenant des agences de
recrutement spécialisé dans le kent
reportage jacques cardoze stéphane
guillemot un domaine plutôt coquet dans
le kent au sud de l'angleterre
le genre de lieu qu'affectionnent
particulièrement les retraités pour
couler des jours paisibles
sauf qu'ici a pris place une agence de
recherche pour l'emploi qui comme le dit
le logo travaille exclusivement pour les
plus de 60 ans l'ambiance dans cette
entreprise est assez décontracté et les
plus de 60 ans après si ça marche
vraiment bien
brian kane n'a pas apprécié de devoir
quitter le monde du travail
prématurément
désormais il en fait son fond de
commerce il a 69 ans et son job c'est
d'en trouver aux autres son fichier
contient 200 candidatures et 40
entreprises
pour lui il y a donc bien un marché pour
cela dans les 20 prochaines années en
grande-bretagne
nous aurons quelque chose comme 11
millions de personnes de plus de 60 ans
ce qui est encore plus intéressant c'est
qu'ils représenteront le tiers de la
population active du pays
alors allons-y messieurs les employeurs
employés donc les plus de 60 ans à la
patinoire du coin on s'est même fait une
spécialité dans le recrutement des
seniors ici tous sont entre 60 et 70 ans
disponible peu exigeants les seniors
sont recherchés et ciblées parfois nous
avons besoin de le matin d'autres fois
le soir la flexibilité quelque chose que
les anciens sont prêts à accepter bien
plus que les jeunes
la flexibilité mais aussi l'expérience
servent les intérêts des patrons
les seniors sont capables d'encadrer les
jeunes d'assurer l'entretien et en plus
ils reviennent moins cher
la plus part des plus de 60 ans sont
encore actifs et veulent faire quelque
chose de différent et pas forcément à
plein temps
cela devient normal à cause de
l'économie actuelle mais aussi parce que
les pensions ici sont dérisoires en
grande bretagne l'âge de la retraite est
fixé à 65 ans pour les hommes et 60 pour
les femmes d'ici 2046 elle devrait
atteindre 68 en mai dans le secteur
privé
certains employeurs veulent aller plus
vite il n'est pas rare de trouver des
septuagénaires au travail
mark fisher est une star de la
relaxation en angleterre son équipe est
d'abord composé de jeunes designers mais
aussi de l'expériementé geremi 72 ans
pour qui le travail n'a d'intérêt que si
l'ailier un objectif si vous travaillez
pour une association le résultat n'a pas
d'importance mais ici c'est le contraire
vous devez y aller et le faire seniors
apporte son expérience son désir
d'entreprendre son engagement au final
il fera tout pour que le projet réussit
sa succession
depuis dix ans la proportion de
travailleurs âgés de plus de 60 ans a
progressé de 10% est aujourd'hui un
tiers des 60 64 ans britanniques
perçoivent un revenu complémentaire
provenant du monde du travail
l'actualité à l'étranger encore avec
l'unanimité qui se fissure en pologne
lech kacynski vous le savez doit être
enterré au vel à cracovie
c'est en quelque sorte le panthéon des
grands hommes là-bas et bien ce choix
est maintenant contestée par une partie
du pays en raison des positions souvent
controversées prises par le défunt
président gérard griesbeck
c'est dans ce château de vaval que
reposeront dimanche le président
polonais son épouse
plus précisément dans la crypte de la
cathédrale de l'ancienne capitale du
royaume de pologne cracovie
ici se trouvent les tombeaux des rois
des héros de l'indépendance
d'intellectuels mais ce lieu divise la
pologne même si à varsovie une foule
immense se recueille encore devant les
cercueils
certains ne voient pas pourquoi le
président serait enterré dans le
panthéon pologne
il ne faut pas l'enterrer là bas il
n'était ni un grand leader ni un artiste
ni au roi à mon avis non malgré tout le
respect et la compassion
non on ne peut pas comparer ce mérite
avec les héros de la pologne
le lieu de l'enterrement est donc devenu
l'objet d'une polémique
une mort tragique foetale un homme
d'état d'envergure s'interroge la presse
sur l'aéroport de varsovie trente deux
cercueils sont arrivés ce matin de
russie
pour l'heure 64 passagers ont été
identifiés sur les 96 qui se trouvaient
dans l'avion qui s'est écrasé samedi
il est 20h20 resté avec nous à suivre la
voc des sports de combat chez les femmes
dans les grandes villes confrontées aux
risques d'agression elles veulent savoir
se défendre c'est le dossier de cette
édition des amateurs contre des
professionnels que vie contre le psg des
millions d'euros laissés par portage à
quelques instants de la demi finale de
la coupe qui sera à suivre sur notre
antenne et puis l'une des plus grandes
scènes de france le printemps de bourges
a commencé hier soit m a électrisé la
foule
nous y étions vous y serez d'abord donc
on poursuit notre série de reportages à
propos des états généraux des femmes a
mené ce printemps par le magazine elle
avec beaucoup d'autres et vous allez
découvrir un phénomène qui n'est plus
marginal
les femmes célibataires ou mères de
famille sont de plus en plus nombreuses
à s'initier aux sports de combat
autant d'ailleurs pour maîtriser leur
peur que pour savoir se défendre
dossiers signés juliette guérin tristan
le braz
célia comme on sait manier larcher avec
délicatesse
mais depuis quelques mois le partage sa
vie entre la musique et le combat
rapproché
cette violoniste a pourtant toujours
voulu préserver ses mains de musicienne
jusqu'à l'an dernier on aller à une
soirée avec des amis dans le rer
et puis voilà une bande de sept garçons
sont venus et et voilà on tabasse et mes
deux amis n'ont donc là je me suis dit
je veux plus je pu assister à ça sans
pouvoir rien faire
sa nouvelle passion l'opérationnel krav
maga ni box myard martial une technique
de défense venus d'israël qui ne répond
à aucune règle son seul objectif
neutraliser l'adversaire
une fois penché il a pris le coup dans
les partis je finis avec un coup
derrière la nuque
notre travail c'est de travailler sur
les points sensibles du corps humain les
parties génitales le coup les yeux la
nuque
mes genoux ont fait en sorte de donner à
la lune importe quelle femme même la
puce est si possible tous les atouts
pour pouvoir au moins avoir le premier
gel comme beaucoup de sports de combat
le travail maga attire de plus en plus
de femmes et +30 % chaque année des
femmes qui refusent de rester des
bourrades idéal pour direct avec le bras
au ciel un immobilier parfois je me
retrouvais dans un espace clos avec les
personnes que je ne connais pas et qui
peuvent être là-bas toujours bien
intentionnés je me sens plus trop si
l'on va dire quand je rentre le soir
seul chez moi
avant j'avais tendance à prendre un taxi
systématiquement mais non je me dis bon
main
j'ai des réflexes ont fait et feront
c'est à dire que quand quelqu'un passe
trop près de moi un peu comme le dit
philippe j'ai tendance à observer la
personne mais c'est déjà un petit peu en
garde etc au calme finalement salle et
vous le dire vous dit comme ça ça peut
changer de la paranoïa mais non c'est je
n'ai pas agressif du tout pour autant
qu'au contraire encore et finalement
c'est surtout la confiance qu'elles
acquièrent un outil presque plus
précieux que la technique or la mesure
mais bien sûr de soi dans le sens où on
apprend à gérer certaines situations et
avoir une attitude
combien de personnes se sont fait
acheter un téléphone combien de
personnes qui sont fait arracher leurs
facs toujours les mêmes celles qui ont
la démarche un petit peu comme ça elle
faisait partie des gens qui baissaient
la tête
aujourd'hui plus de la moitié des
violences déclarées sont portés sur des
femmes
celle ci pourrait désormais donner du
fil à retordre à leurs agresseurs
c'est souvent quand il raconte des
histoires que le sport est le plus beau
est bien celle qui s'écrit ce soir se
situe dans la grande lignée de la coupe
de france de football c'est une nouvelle
version du pot de terre contre le pot de
fer
d'un côté que vie des amateurs quelques
semi professionnelle et de l'autre le
paris saint germain et ses stars julien
benedetto michael cariou il aborde le
match de leur vie en toute décontraction
sur les sentiers de la gloire
le petit poucet découvre ce matin le
stade de caen théâtre de la demi-finale
léger entraînement et lecture assidue de
la presse locale commence à prendre
conscience qu'on fait quelque chose de
dénommer
ce soir vous ce soir encore plus beaux
clubs la fête soit encore plus belle est
gigantesque
quevilly club de 4e division et aux
portes du stade de france après avoir
éliminé deux clubs de ligue 1 la plupart
des héros sont footballeurs amateurs
certains ont dû poser un jour de congé
pour la demi finale
c'est le cas de fodié traoré le milieu
défensif et policiers mon entraîneur par
exemple au niveau sportif s'adapte par
rapport aux horaires que de travail donc
quand je suis partante du matin il
essaye de mettre l'entraînement à
musique plus vip et lg choc des extrêmes
yannick passa attaquant et magazine in
touch 1500 euros par mois
en face de lui ce soir claude makelele
émarge à 300000 euros mensuels
de quoi payer 10 fois toute l'équipe de
quevilly les stars du psg il est voit à
la télé d'habitude alors cet après midi
l'entraîneur harangue ses troupes
grandiose est persuadé de ça parce
qu'ils avaient toutes les possibilités
toutes les qualités tout le potentiel ce
que vous avez jusqu'à présent c'est pas
pour rien trois divisions et des
millions d'euros c'est par quevilly du
psg
mais la petite ville normande rêve quand
même d'une nouvelle nuit de folie et
pour le plaisir un coup de en direct sur
le stade et ses gradins le match joie
quand un stade michel d'ornano 21 mille
spectateurs qui attendent le coup
d'envoi c'est à suivre en direct dans
quelques instants avec fabien lévêque et
xavier gravelaine aux commentaires le
vainqueur affrontera monaco en finale
monaco vainqueur de lens hier un but
à 0 but signé mazouz dans les
prolongations les deux équipes étaient à
égalité au coup de sifflet final avant
les prolongations
c'est parti pour le printemps de bourges
l'un des plus grands festivals de france
soirée groove et rock
hier avec matthieu chedid alias m dans
la foule christophe airaud nicolas
ducron milieu d'après midi mathieu
chedid est en balance derniers réglages
et répétitions
en ouverture du festival il ya un
concert de m quelques heures auparavant
il était le premier sur le pont balade
bucolique et rencontre avec une jeune
chanteuse qui lui offre son premier
album offert un festival qu'on se
prostituer pour ses contres et c'est ça
qui est très doux dans les festivals et
qui est très plaisant c'est à dire c'est
tout c'est de pouvoir effectivement
voilà rliss relié à d'autres gens et
surtout pas forcément coco plus
confirmés
20 heures c'est parti pour deux heures
de musique
c'est sûr que c'est pour moi un miracle
à l'heure d'aujourd'hui de faire déjà
des disques sur des spectacles d'avoir
des gens qui sont là pour pour échanger
j'allais dire et pour vivre une
expérience puisque c'est vrai que si on
fait ça ensemble le spectacle s'il est
réussi c'est parce que le public y
contribue beaucoup
à près de 40 ans et cinq albums matthieu
chedid a connu tous les succès pour
éviter la routine et s'est entouré de
nouveaux musiciens jamais fait devrait
tourner ce qui est c'est génial parce
que ça permet aussi à travers de vivre
les premières fois de vivre les premiers
émois l'epr
bourges ce n'était qu'une étape la
tournée finira le 19 décembre à paris
soit huit mois de route de concert pour
matthieu chedid
avant de refermer ce journal je vous en
rappelle l'un des principaux titres la
grève fait trébucher la sncf à la veille
des départs en vacances la vente de
billets tgv totalement suspendu entre le
sud-est et par y aller et retour
l'entreprise ne peut plus garantir la
circulation des trains c'est le neuvième
jour de grève à la sncf
merci à vous tous tout de suite la météo
tania young qui nous promettra une
petite percée du soleil 20h35 la coupe
de france donc 22h35 raid eric lopez
sème la panique dans l'oreillette une
heure des mots de minuit philippe lefait
à demain
l'info en continu
c'est aussi sur france 2 point fr